the real rejects journal is a video
we're gonna do an unboxing and a review
of the first episode of Watchmen
recently a man named Phil most people
don't say their contacts name I do yeah
we're different
what's your back Phil watch your back we
know where you live working in
corresponds with HBO they said they
wanted to send us over a package to
unbox now we had two choices we could
have done this before the episode came
out the season premiere or watch the
first episode and then unbox it so we
decided to go with the latter here but
if you don't care for the unboxing part
you can skip ahead to the review portion
if you do want to see what's in this box
we have no idea what there's no heads-up
of it at all of what's gonna be in this
box it's so neat and pretty special
let's check it out stab that tape
Rorschach's vlog channel roars Xterra
food right here oh no I'm gonna hold
this scoot it down
just Splore pit out of the can there oh
yeah we got a blood drip blood drip to
watch man alot since so far so watchman
okay we've opened the box real region oh
says our name custom put real Regis it's
heavy there's not a heavy ache more holy
like that it's pointy on the bottom -
whoa oh snap a kiss oh look a
traditional seola was sealing wax we've
probably got a letter from Adrian or
fight it's time it's time catch the
series premiere which is hurt yeah that
it was a custom letter I think they
wanted us to unbox this before the show
came we're gonna get what we got here
for the fires we can protect our
breathing oh wow well that's
cool-looking yeah yes oh that's the
ideal way to wear this perfect you want
some help there
oh yeah fire mask Rorschach's breathing
yeah you look like sub-zero a little bit
I'm gonna grab this thing I don't know
what it is but it's got a little squiddy
and it's a swatch so I'm gonna guess
that this is some kind of timepiece who
wears a watch of the Watchmen one of us
swatch you can't see it cuz the
reflections and the lights but lookee
here tick tock tick tock set top in
reference to the Ke$ha song to wake up
in the morning feeling like the world's
gonna beat me to a joke this way you
could say tick tock like the white
supremacist characters oh look out Wow
who wears the large sweater John I'm the
large there's a large that means I'm the
guy who needs to keep better track of
time you can have the watch Thanks oh
the review so I can keep track that
we're not talking to I would love if
this was just a doomsday watch though
counting down to the end of the world
and not just the hours of the day was
warm in Los Angeles today but I'm still
cool don't look up and shout what time
is it and I will whisper tick tock time
free time to get him watch
I look like Regina Kings sister night
right here dude and I look like I've got
a cool watch look like a watchman fan
wow I don't have a sweater I don't have
a face mask that looks like that one can
I try it on no they on your face
I looked it a lot oh yeah it's wet Thank
You Phil and thanks over at HBO for
sending this over to us thanks to the
home box office is there so this is
gonna be great for for thumbnail hey
let's get that thumbnail that thumbnail
pose out of the way where's the bottom
thank you guys for sent over onto the
show what a shitty show I hated
every I hated every second of this show
don't watch it but make sure to buy
yourself some Watchmen merch I had my
hesitations towards the show I think
everyone in the world you know I watched
an interview with Alan Moore and
actually just a couple weeks ago where
he was talking about he doesn't watch
the movies and I think like the way how
people have interpreted how he's talked
about that has been like he's just like
infuriating
really it's just a choice because it
sounds like more like he doesn't want to
influence his brain and he just he wrote
it for a specific medium he just doesn't
care for it but it's not like this huge
disdain or hatred necessarily at least
it's out whether there's like a 30
minute interview i watch with a guy and
that's just how he came across to me I
feel like it's kind of important to know
jack cuz he had nothing to do with this
show I know that he was upset about the
fact that DC has taken his characters
and made prequels I know that was
upsetting to him it's also important to
note that this show most of the Watchmen
movie is faithful but in terms of plot
points towards the graphic novel but
they changed certain things and the
ending of the movie and the graphic
novel Ozymandias teleports like a giant
squid monster thing they can unite the
globe common enemy come take us away
from our pants waffle rants dimensional
being but in the movie turning into it's
just dr. Manhattan takes the credit
exactly and I think it's kind of
important to know because this whole
thing that happens with there's gonna be
spoilers here there's gonna be this Oh
doubt there's a whole thing that happens
with like where it's like raining squids
mmm at one point and I feel like if you
don't remember the comic oh you're gonna
be like what I don't get it well and
then we're reading some fan responses
there are people like they're throwing
in random stuff like squid rain and I
was like well no actually it kind of
pertains yeah I don't know what they're
gonna do with it yet but yeah as far as
this show itself goes I thought there
was gonna be some type of prelude to
explain the events of the Watchmen comic
look at that takes place an alternate
version of the 80s and I thought there's
gonna be some type of explanation they
don't do any of that with it which kind
of took them threw me for a loop
actually yeah cuz I was like okay I
really got to remember what I read like
ten years ago yeah yeah for context and
for the themes that they're going for
because I think it's really interesting
what they've done here and then they've
Damon Lindelof at least has talked at
length about why he decided to do this
now after several offer
and all that but I think that it is
interesting that you don't necessarily
have to have seen Watchmen the movie or
read the graphic novel to completely
enjoy what is being presented here I
think it you should if you really want
the complete experience but I think as a
dramatic piece you know it is intriguing
it does draw you in and it has these
themes that are based on tensions in the
world now so I feel like there's
relevant stuff you can get yeah out of
it and cool details you can it's an
alternate version of present-day a focus
isn't alsa Oklahoma it's like what if
the watch adds it's the same universe as
the graphic novel just progressed up
until now yeah so you got some weird
rule things to it law enforcement all
wear masks now which I thought was a
neat touch to it their interrogation
processes are rather unique
yeah there's a white supremacist cult on
the rise which follows in the footsteps
of Rorschach I did not read audience
reactions to this but I did notice on
Rotten Tomatoes that it had a really
high credit score an extremely low
audience score which immediately told me
one thing yeah there must be a lot of
political perhaps SJW things in there
right that's what I suspected I'm like
that just must be what it is that tends
to happen with these project approach on
political relevance you're SJW us and
you should get it out of my
entertainment now I think it's important
to note Watchmen in and of itself is
very political it's extremely political
you just have to read the graphic novel
to get that sense even the movie watch
the movie clearly clearly political
ideas on Vietnam War so much of cutting
and Nixon nuclear terror all these
things and then society all the
perspective rather and then class
differences and yeah so this doesn't
exactly feel like the comic to me but I
think in terms of a continuation cutting
to twenty thirty years later I think it
works on its own I think an appreciation
for the graphic novel but taking this on
its own merits I really do think it
works tonally stylistically I think
there are people who have been very
upset with how is Rorschach an influence
for a white supremacist calling because
he's the coolest character who's like
the wounds look good yeah
the lunar DS also Alan Moore has talked
about its influences to be concerning
Lee alright
yeah character and ashes character
definitely honestly like the first time
I saw Rorschach in like the movies in
the comedies I was like I was like oh
he's so cool but you think about what
he's there to represent more than just
what he is as an individual
he's anti-communist he's anti-liberal
nationalism it's got a lot of rain even
the the diary that he submits it to the
new frontiersman at the end of the
watchman graph a novel is as a
right-wing conspiracy you think so
literally if you're gonna update this
for modern-day and then reflect the
landscape of today to me it's not
far-fetched and I also don't think it's
quite a literal this is how this cult
has interpreted Rorschach's Journal yeah
and and take it to them and it's like I
don't think this is what Rorschach
wanted well then it makes sense to me
how the interpretation landed this way
yeah and I think part of the point of
Watchmen if you really get down to it is
that all these different people with
these you know personas that are out
here trying to do their version of
justice in the world all come from very
different backgrounds with very
different points so yeah you and what
happened you know it's begging the
question that what if you don't just
have a guy with absolute power and an
absolute interesting good I read some of
the fan reactions and it seemed like
there were kind of three camps it was
either this is a really cool HBO show
and and I'm open to it or this is not my
watch man you know screw this or what is
this it's too slow it's too political I
don't get it it's not you know fun or
action or whatever there's a lot here
that people probably haven't read about
in the inception of the show it's like
if you don't keep up with movie news and
watching it my worries were kind of at
least dissuade enough to make me curious
to continue it because it does seem like
now is a decent time and place to
revisit these themes through this scope
superheroes or as big as they've ever
been and this shows yeah what if we had
these vigilante personas in a world
where you know police violence is where
it is now and they're interacting and
there's you know racial tensions on the
rise like yeah I can apply to now I just
got a completely disagree with the whole
thing of it being political heavy-handed
it being that being a problem because
I'm like no the whole point with
Watchmen it was a reflection of the time
when they go in the conchae on an
alternate version of that time but it
was also a commentary in a
a tire of sorts at that time if you
wanted your cool superheroes and I'm
like and so to do the modern-day version
I'm like well there's kind of they're
essentially doing the direction of kind
of what Alan Moore did with that time
and putting into today hey I'm okay with
that and then be with it with the way
this the plot of the show actually
unfolds I think it's really cool it's
got kind of this ominous tone it's very
mysterious for a show that has so much
rules and world building they're not
heavily reliant at all on expositional
dialog you something you really got to
pay attention to while there's a lot of
things fanatically that it's exploring
especially within this first episode of
dealing with racism I still think that
they managed to keep it very human and
character driven especially with the
characters of Don Johnson and Regina
King now Regina King I think is a
phenomenal performance she's great in
the show and I think she's a total
badass and I like I like the SJW role
exactly what a ton and everything every
moment is what a silly polarizer this is
a moment towards the end of the episode
though which he goes into the bed gets
the shotgun and then hands him a gun
like I need you to shoot anyone who
comes on the porch he's like okay
they're afar like Jesus unconditionally
supportive no matter what like no the
thing is like there's no fear at all in
his performances yeah yeah to me that's
where a kind of crosses a little bit of
a line in terms of she is full-blown
vigilante character I don't feel any
fear for this human being when she's in
charge okay she still seems like on the
super heroic side he's gonna make it out
yeah I mean I mean I'd be surprised the
show kills her off that's like the one
little complaint for the very humanizing
portrayal of these because you know you
don't have your crazy sci-fi characters
like dr. Manhattan at least not yet yeah
there's a shot it's attention to detail
and the rules are really cool like
something as little as for the cops to
access their guns and yet permission
yeah and how that becomes a big part of
the plot is allowing the cops to just
use their guns without having to require
permission yeah and it creates this
interesting vibe where yeah it's
extrapolating on both watchmen and our
time now because yeah that masks the
permission for the weapons and stuff it
seems like regulations that could very
well go into place now or you know in a
not too distant future I think
this is gonna be something interesting
to watch I like that they're not overly
explaining things I like when a show
will allow you to kind of pick up the
world as you go I thought they drew the
mysteries enough that I wanted to keep
watching them I really liked a lot of
the character development a lot of the
different hero personas especially
looking glass the whole interrogation
scene I thought was really interesting I
just thought this was a solid pilot not
every pilot is solid and I thought the
performers were all good it got me
intrigued this felt grounded in a way
where I'm like I'm curious to watch this
continue more that I'm worried I feel
like this could actually manage to be
smart engaging thrilling I just think
people are gonna have to decide whether
they want to be patient about that Don
Johnson's character I was really I was
really bummed like it gets killed in the
end I had a point when I was watching
this show thinking it's so cool
that Don Johnson finally had a show like
I had this thought like this is a big
show tunes and Don Johnson deserves a
big shot he killed off in the first
episode which is a real bummer yeah it's
a striking moment but yes and I felt
like he was such a big part of this
first episode it's a big presence yeah
like he's pretty much treated like one
of the main care like him and Regina
King or the main characters on he's the
chief of the police department yeah
they're so like that's a big that's a
big shot fired so I'm curious to see how
the remaining episodes will unfold and a
lot of unrest I predicted yeah cuz
there's yeah I think there's a definite
reason they started with the black wall
street riots and stuff like that yeah
and the guy in the wheelchair - I was
like one of the few survivors of that
and he had the note when Don Johnson's
being hung yeah watch over this boy yeah
exactly so I don't know he might be the
boy mm-hmm that's just like the best
guess I guess yeah I feel like that's
probably what they're implying yeah
overall though I didn't think it was a
really good show but there's nothing
really I didn't like about it I think
that the music is also wonderful Trent
Reznor and Atticus run know when you
said Trevor Eisner especially I'm like
yeah what I read that I was like oh okay
I didn't like name it in my head but not
every shot is composed like it is super
stylish but when they decide to do that
I think it's great yeah I thought this
they had a I like the direction - I
thought it was thoughtful they knew when
to be stylized they knew when to pick an
angle that's interesting but not too
in-your-face and stick with it for a
while and I think for its pacing they're
slowly fleshing out this world and show
don't think you're meant to understand
everything right away I think a lot of
it is meant to intrigue you it's meant
to raise questions like everything with
Ozymandias is kind of like all right
yeah that's weird
yeah were these servants did he build
never say create these humans and like
what what is it yeah it is a show that
seems like it begs you to go back and
pick up details not that it is heavily
laced with like cheeky Easter eggs but I
think there are a lot of nuances that
they're gonna throw at you that aren't
necessarily gonna be in your face and I
feel like it is a show hopefully that
will give you back more on repeat again
I feel like for this medium it behooves
you to be open you know it's like every
episode has to give you enough that you
want to continue but I feel like it is
good to be open to mystery in a place
like this a pilot isn't supposed to give
you all the answers it's supposed to
raise questions all right guys well did
you guys see the first episode of
Watchmen leave your comments down below
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
thank you again for sending over these
awesome goodies